it was about four o'clock in the morning
and I heard these loud bangs one after
the other but it took me a few seconds
to wake up and realize what was going on
and then as the months went by you could
see that the country was still organized
the institutions were still there
ukrainians were still following the
rules there's a sense of civic duty
senior correspondent for Al Jazeera and
between us each time I returned to
Ukraine I continue to be struck about
how the country is holding together
despite the young men's suffering and
devastation
now remember I went once to the front
line in zapparija we arrived and there
was this elderly woman who was sweeping
the floor and I said what are you doing
she said we have to keep our village
clean and you could hear the artillery
outgoing and incoming she wasn't
flinching she took me to some basement
and I walked in this basement and all of
us the whole team we were completely
amazed there was a group of women maybe
10 of them all in their 50s and above
all living there alone if the Russians
had pushed forward and they were only
five kilometers away they said that they
were gonna get out of their shelter
stand there and explain to the Russians
that this is not their country and they
should leave
[Music]
I have been covering Ukraine since 2014
and many ukrainians would tell you you
know we have been at War for the past
eight years I remember going to Crimea
and at the time the Russian soldiers
were slowly daily uh coming into that
Peninsula and I remember thinking that
there was very little resistance from
the ukrainians but people would tell you
this is not the same Ukraine
this is not the same Army and this time
we will defend ourselves
and I think where you have the upper
hand here is that there is really a
belief among ukrainians that this is
their cause they are on the right side
they are not the aggressor
I was holding my breath when the
counter-offensive in the northeast of
the country started
I found the country was so high because
the Russians were retreating it's so
good we are Ukraine we arrived in Israel
you walk into this forest and you see
these
hundreds of crosses on top of little
mounds of sand next to a cemetery just a
few had names on them the rest were just
crosses you didn't know who they were it
was also shocking to see these poor
forensic experts digging out these
bodies a smell literally stayed under my
nose for days on end
after that each time we went to a newly
liberated area
you know you had this apprehension how
many bodies are we going to see how much
more are we going to see because it is a
terrible scene and what really surprised
me in all of that is that you had family
members you had friends who were coming
there to ask
about their loved ones and they were so
collected and so calm and so olderly and
following instructions despite you could
see all that pain etched on their face
and that's the moment I'll never ever
forget people looking for the bodies of
their loved ones regardless of how they
died is just quite shocking
I think the attacks on the big cities
the attacks on the infrastructure on the
power stations on the water supply chain
and that will continue and in all of
that you still have ukrainians who tell
you we will continue fighting even if we
have to spend the winter in the cold and
in the dark and bear in mind that a lot
of people lost winter especially the
elderly had died of cold in areas that
were under bombardment
I could not sometimes stand in the
street for more than five to eight
minutes
it's Sub-Zero during the day it could be
minus 20 degrees centigrade and then it
go down at night to minus 30 as the
colder days approach I really wonder
what ukrainians are gonna do I mean they
have small children they have elderly
parents uh vulnerable population that
cannot survive in that cold and that
really worries me a lot because I did
feel that cold and it's really terrible
foreign
[Music]